i'm not surprised at all that they took
away my citizenship and to be honest
having british and [ __ ] british
citizenship in this
time this current political situation is
exactly the same as not having british
any british citizenship i've been here
for two and a half years i've been
abroad in a prison for the last two and
a half years without trial
no one's even asked about me from the
british government what does it mean to
be a british sisters in any way
any to be honest i don't care i don't
want practitioners it's just a piece of
paper i'm not even i don't even
recognize it
do you have any message for the prime
minister or for the british home
secretary at the moment jack
i don't really want to speak to him
directly and
at the same time i don't think it makes
much difference yeah but i can say to
him i don't want your
passport i don't want your citizenship
anyway so keep it any i don't want it
i'm aware that canada hasn't as far as i
know stripped me of the
citizenship which is i suppose a good
sign
but like i said i've been here for two
and a half years without trying without
even a visit
i can't even speak to my mum or father
for more than two years
i was brought up believing that canada
was always a bit better than britain
i think that's the case to be honest if
if canada can genuinely
genuinely consider me a a citizen etc
then i'd like them to help me i'd like
to take me out from here it's been two
and a half years like i said without
trial
and it's just quite ridiculous to be
honest you know i'm not a murderer i
never took anyone as a slave and ever
i made just a stupid mistake in coming
to syria and if i have to be
put to trial etcetera then not into some
haphazard way just kept in a
prison abroad would you say to the
canadian prime minister or the canadian
government if you were sitting face to
face with them would you what kind of
appeal would you make to them do you
think
i don't want to try and persuade anyone
or or irritate anyone to
help me if they don't want to help me
they're not going to help me any me
trying to persuade them we're not just
going to
not going to convince a whole state or a
whole country to come and
save me like some sort of superman film
it doesn't i don't want to do that if
they want to help me they'll help me and
i'd love that it'll be brilliant but i
don't think me saying
you should do it because of this is
going to make any difference they have
their own decisions that they make and
that's all your parents have told
canadian newspapers that that they've
been left destitute
by the court action the british
government took against them
about sending you money they can't sleep
and the whole affair has
has devastated the family do you feel
guilty about that do you
what do you regret most about all this
of course i feel guilty i mean that's
one of the
worst things about being in this place
because i know i've done something wrong
and i'm not in a position to put it
right because i have no
way of doing so here that makes sense of
course i feel guilty
with a stupid decision i made i ruined
my family and
i don't know to what extent because
there's some things i don't actually
know what happened in
in britain but i know where the state of
my family is terrible
you know i wait for two months or
sometimes more than two months until the
red cross comes here just to hear if
they're in prison or not
and they have nothing to they're not
terrorists i think that's something the
whole world has sort of understood
in this uh weird period but of course of
course i feel guilty honey
it's my mum and dad it's one of the
worst things about being in this prison
is i can't do anything about it
what do you think that other british
young people
can learn from what you've done what
what can they learn from your experience
going away joining an extremist
organization the question is mainly
going to be
directed to the muslims in britain of
course because the decision i made is
very
directly related to islam
and the fact that i became muslim and i
am muslim
i think so in in asking that
at the moment i'm going to have to sort
of reply to the muslims in britain so i
would advise them to
first off learn their religion properly
any
the reason i came here or the sort of
the trap that i fell into here was
all due to the fact that i didn't learn
my religion properly i didn't understand
what the
fundamental principle of islam was and
etc i mean i didn't i didn't understand
what i was doing because i had
a lot of ignorance so they should learn
the religion properly they should go
back to the
fundamental aspects of islam that would
obviously stop them if they acted by it
from making these sort of crazy mistakes
i advise anyone who's gonna
judge me or i don't mean in a court
sense i mean
in their own selves and anyone who's
gonna
try and judge me or make have their own
opinion about what happened to me in
syria what happened with my mom what
happened with my dad etc
then they should wait until the whole
story really comes out anything should
be based on evidence
things should be based on what actually
happened with the way that you
that can be proved not just on things
that i may have said in prison because
you know what prisons are like and you
know what
any anyway i don't want to go into too
much detail here but things should
always be based on evidence